un candidato menos en la carrera para
suceder a gotabaya rajapaksa el
principal opositor sayid premadasa
declinó sus aspiraciones para respaldar
adular a la fape luna un ex periodista
cinco veces legislador y visto como un
político de bajo perfil
la gente que está en el parlamento en
esta pequeña isla rodeada por el lago di
yaguana no puede entender la voz de la
gente que está afuera en el ine no es un
viejo lo único que piden es que se
cambie esta cultura política que se
introduzca una nueva cultura que se
reúna al pueblo
mi página
hicimos este sacrificio por la gente
cómodo y las victorias políticas
personales deben convertirse en
victorias para el país
aportaba servat andina
lo que queremos es que gane el país
queremos que gane el pueblo
entre los candidatos está el presidente
en funciones running we creeme singer
quien causa malestar entre la población
por tener el respaldo de los raya pax a
la gente volvió a las calles esta vez
para exigir que él no sea elegido como
sucesor
si tenemos un país en el que no hay
colas en el que tenemos comida para
comer en el que se cuida la educación de
los niños y en el que la gente vive en
libertad eso es suficiente no puede
haber más mentiras ni corrupción si eso
ocurre volveremos a salir a la calle
todos nosotros saldremos a la calle
el parlamento con 225 escaños votará
este miércoles para elegir al nuevo
presidente que deberá intentar conjurar
la crisis en la que está sumida esta
isla de asia del sur las manifestaciones
en serie' lanka llevan meses atizadas
por los altos precios del combustible y
la comida además el país debe al fondo
monetariointernacional unos 51 mil
millones de dólares por lo que no puede
acceder a préstamos de emergencia que lo
ayudarían a salir a flote